HOW'S IT GOING BROS?
My name's PEWDIEPI-
...The fuck, that's my legs!
EDGAR! What are you doing?!
Anyway, welcome my SISTERS(pudipa,stop calling us "Sisters" its really annoying)
...to...
notmortality was here
FRYDAYS WITH PEEEEWWWDEEEPAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA(I MISS THIS SO MUCH :,)
Today we're going through you guys' submissions for the green screen competition.
I recorded myself in front of a green screen.
I asked you guys to submit your edits, and now, we're gonna watch.
*satisfied clap*
I usually love these, I'm so fucking excited to watch,
...aeh...
Been trying hard to avoid cheating, because
Some of them look really fucking funny already.
Also, I'm announcing a new competition, link is in the description. All the info will be in the end of the video.
LET'S GOOOOooooOOuhhOOoOOO
Oh God... How- *laugh*
"ah kicke!"
DyaHAHYAHA!
I mean no, that's horrible!!!!
Let's watch that again.
*comedy*
That looks legit...
...Wha happened? *laughing*
*Some more comedy*
Kids, listen. I know it's upsetting, a kid got hurt
...but that's how kids learn. Okay?
That kid just learned a valuable lesson that day.
...AND THAT'S NOT TO MESS WITH ME!(damn,he goes hard)
*immortal village song*
Casa de la Pewds.
Hell yeah.
"Ugh, it's coming out of my ass!"
"Oh shit, dawg."
"Oh, it's a big one."
"AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH"
*majestic flying burger*
"AHHHHH"
"Ah, shit, that hurt. Ow."
"What the, fu-... why did it pause?"
*Poopiepie laughs* BOO!
"Jesus, fuck..!"
"Hey how's it going?"
"You're...you're..."
"PEWDIEPIE"
"Yeah...and...you're on my computer...screen..."
"... Um... okay... um, so what... what did... what did you... what did you think?"
"That is..."
"Yeah?"
Retarded
**laughing**"R-Really? That's all you have to say?"
"I worked really hard on this."
"Fuck you."
"Y'know what, motherfucker? Here..."
I'm just gonna drag you over here... "Ah OW, MY EAR!"
"And I'm coming in there."
"Alright, bring that ass here, Swedish bitch."
WTF IS HAPPENING!!! *LAUGHING**
Narrator: SPEQTOR
Narrator: PEWDIEPIE
Narrator: FIGHT!!!!
*poopidie laughs*
HELL YEAH!
FUCK HIM UP, PEWDS!~
COME ON, PEWDIEPIE
C'MON!
"aeh kicke"
Finish HIM!!
*exactly what you expected*
PEWDIEPIE WINS!!
Did he just edit himself to win-
to lose?
God bless you, man.
You, you could've
You could've went for that win
but just because you made yourself lose,
I respect you. *clapping* I respect you...
Major respect.
And if you're a wahmen, I double respect.
*self inflict*
*fan girl service*
That's fuckin' awesome.
Really creative.
Really like it.
*Ed, Edd, n Eddy reference*
I am disgusted by this content. It makes me sick.
Ya like this fidget-spinning, boi?
Well check this out.
*star wars sound effects* That's right.
Hey, it's become kind of a symbol... OHHH
*laugh*
Oh!!! xD
****LAUGHING****
The last meme was beautiful. Good job, good job.
"Hey how's it going bros? My name is PEWDIEPIE!"
"PEWDIEPIE!"
"PEWDIE PEWDIEPIE!"
This is fire.
Hell yeah.
#MusicContinue
*Laughing!!!*
EDGAR: I Can Dance Better Than U,Felix!
*LAUGHING!!!*
That was fucking awesome, man.
Jesus.
I love the Edgar bit.
OH I'M SO STRONG!! OH!!!! HAHAHA!!!
Do One Hand Boi!!!!
Ahhhhhh
That's some quality editing, right there.
Well done.
Oh, what the fuck?!
Who's faster?
"You the man, bitch!"
*PewDiePie's Smile*
Oh my God.
Hell yeah!
"Who are you?"
"MY NAME... JEEEFF!"
AHAHA!!!!!!
YEAH!
FUCK HIM UP!
"I don't know who you are!"
"Mah name is PewDiePaaah!"
*Clapping*
YEAH, THAT WAS FUCKING AWESOME!
THAT FUCKING EDITING!
Jesus Christ!
Who Are You??
Ma Name Is JEFF!!!!
AHH, IT'S SO RETARDED
I LOVE IT, JESUS CHRIST!
HELL YEAH
Awh, this is so funny.
It's so shit but it's so funny, goddamn it.
Oh shit, it's Dolan Darker
I've seen the movie, so you know what fucking shit is gonna happen...
tehahaha
Don't Open The Door!
"Gonna eat your ass, boi!"
*laugh* I've seen the end of this one.
That was good shit.
Man, that movie is so fucking scary.
I remember when I saw that.
It freaked me out, man.
Ayy, it's another door opening.
It's another door opening meme.
"Hey, baby."
"Don't be shy."
"Come on in!"
GODDAMN IT.
Whoa, that looks legit!
"Hey, how's it going, bros?"
"MY NAME IS PEEEWDIEPIE"
Oh, it's white. I told you it was white.
Think it'll scare the kids?
*ting*
*ting ting ting*
"SO FAST!"
It's fantastic.
So retarded, I love it, Jesus Christ.
It's so fucking hot in here, I'm so delirious.
Hey, it's Day by Dave
Ayy-heyy
I like it, it's fucking good.
Always good shit, man. Always good.
Old green screen pewds: Oh I love this
OGP: feels hot
nice and spicy
New green screen pewds: oh i like it hehe
OGP:this feels like my mom's buttcheeks
NGP: -intense moaning-
OGP: I love shaking my hips like this
NGP: ahh its coming out of my ass
oh shit dawg
oh it's a big one
OGP: oh mama
-screams-
I love the room music in the background as well.
It's a behbe! (baby)
I love it so much.
You're gonna be such a great mother :)
*poorly sings along*
ooh... it's hard to grab it
just gimme a lil...
Ohhh my God, what the fuck?!
STOOOOOOOOP
-wretching sounds-
Another movie meme? What do we got?
*flawless acting* OH! YOU SCARED MEEEE!
Ya like my fidget-spinning?
Well I can fidget your fffff-
Fuck you.
DESTROY IT!
Destroy it!
What? Why?
why..WHY
Just let it go.
You like this fidget spinning, boy?
You like this fidget spinning boy?
Well check this out
'psh'
Well check this out, 'psh'
That's right.
Caught it with my ass
Nooo!
YESS
That's how fidget spinners work.
If you haven't tried it, I really recommend you do it right now.
HELL YEAH
THE SONGS ARE AWESOME!
DAMN, THE EDITING IS SICK!
It's not bad. It's pretty good.
WHAT'S IN THE BOX? WHAT'S IN THE FUCKING BOX?
It's ya boi, PeeewDiePie
NO!
NO!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
Why are you so upset?
I would be happy if I was inside a box.
taaaakeee onnnn meeeee
taaaakke onnnn meEEEEE
I'LL (just screams at this point)
-continous screaming-
-some sort of dinosaur mating call?-
This is so retarded, what the fuck is this shit?
???
Man...
These are my favorite videos to shoot.
You guys are so funny, creative...
Actually, just kidding, you're not that great.
I want you to end up like me.
Next week,
post your best PewDiePie Meme
Same sub-reddit, same rules.
Go ahead and vote; so like, the good ones get on top.
And I can't thank you guys enough for making these submissions.
I'll leave all the channels that I reviewed in the description if you wanna check them out.
Yeah. Just bros supporting bros.
I mean, sisters supporting fisters
Seriously, it really warms my heart to see these sort of things.
And not because I'm fucking dying of sweat and heat.
But also, because, *kissy kiss* I love you guys,
in a very sexual manner.
I feel like I can't make that kind of joke in this current landscape.
ANYWAY!
STAY AWESOME, SISTER FIIISTERRRRRR!
*EPIC ENDING*